My wish
[music]
Yes
10 years ago it was my favorite TV show called The
Great Villain The purpose of the great villain was to rule the world
If everyone attacked him for that then his real
purpose would be different
[music] I
'm a stand-in  I was trying to make peace that ruled the world
[music]
Hey
Hoshimiya age
Goodbye
I wanted to be like a big villain
That's why
I wished
back then I want to
rule the world I'll win the end  I didn't know what kind of ability it
was, but it doesn't matter.
With this, my father and mother are enemies.
Why am I treating this child?
Ability
At least the male is erotic
[music]
Restraining ruler
by Tori writer
re
th
This is this, this is a territory
After I walk, it becomes a claw-breaking territory
If it is in the territory that had the same ability as the substitute 1
Freedom to rule over anything
And I have an underground parking lot as territory Staff
here I can walk right above it
[music]
[applause]
[music] It's
Ueda